esta es la primera vez que tanto cámara
de representantes y senado a lula el
veto presidencial de trump que pretendía
frenar la ley de financiación de defensa
cercana a los 740 mil millones de
dólares para este año
sólo intentaba evitarla porque quería
acabar con la sesión 230 que no permitía
demandar a las redes sociales por el
contenido que publicaban sus usuarios en
otras palabras es una victoria para las
plataformas sociales por otro lado
mañana al mediodía hora de washington se
posesionará un nuevo congreso de eeuu el
evento sería particular después de que
el congresista electo look network
muriera cinco días antes de posesionarse
debido precisamente al cob y el evento
de juramentación de hecho se hará en
siete grupos que irán a plenaria en
horarios diferentes para evitar el
contagio un principio de año bastante
movido en washington ya que el 5 de
enero será la elección de dos senadores
de georgia que estaban pendientes que
podrían definir la mayoría en el senado
y el 6 de enero será la confirmación de
joe biden en el congreso una
confirmación que tendrá que votarse en
dos cámaras
que se presentará no presiones de
algunos congresistas republicanos